it's official tag heuer 'he's launched a
SmartWatch and they've got Google and
Intel on board
at the Basel world watch show these
three companies laid down the gauntlet
to the rest of the industry by
announcing the first luxury SmartWatch
with Android wear the original idea was
to make a connected watch because
believe that there is a market in future
for connected watches genius now Michael
what should not be just a product that
tells you what time it is or that should
only connect you the watch needs a third
dimension that's the dimension of dream
it's a dimension of emotion
it's the dimension of desirability it's
the dimension of sex appeal
it's it amaze the dimension of design
it's the dimension of beauty all this
will be in the tag or you're connected
one and all this will make the watch
different
but to make this a reality tag heuer had
to look beyond switzerland to experts
and chipsets not movement a big part of
it is to have a power efficient enough
chip that you can let the software run a
wild I've never actually found something
that has too much battery life so
software always manages to find a way to
take up whatever slack we build in from
a hardware perspective having hardware
and software work together from the
beginning provides lots of opportunities
Intel together with other partners that
we have are able to go really deep with
Android wear and we can think a lot
about what are the right sensors to
bring to a platform and a device what
are the right display technologies to
select for the exact look and feel that
we want to achieve there and it's
definitely the case that by using those
three companies expertise together in
partnership that we can achieve
it's strange to think but in just a few
years we could hear these guys talking
about software - I think the
counterparts will be will be surprised
that we managed who to come to help
first the idea to try to get this
mothership and number two that we
managed to get it and they might
starting asking themselves why haven't
we done it